WERE HUNDREDS OF PROTESTERS
GATHERING ONCE AGAIN TONIGHT,
BUT FIRST CHRISTINE FISHER AT
THE WHITE HOUSE WITH NEW
INFORMATION ON WHAT REALLY WENT
DOWN LAST NIGHT ON THE NORTH
LAWN.
>> MOMENTS AGO THE U.S. PARK
POLICE PUT OUT A STATEMENT
SAYING THAT NO TEAR GAS WAS USED
DURING THAT TO PUSH BACK OF
PROTESTERS IN LAFAYETTE SQUARE.
THIS TIME LAST NIGHT.
NOW DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL
SAYING THAT THOSE PROTESTERS
WERE PEACEFUL, BUT THE PARK
POLICE SAYING THAT SOME
PROCESSORS -- PROTESTERS WERE
COMBATIVE AND THROUGH
PROJECTILES FORCING THEM TO
ESCALATE.
ONE DAY AFTER LAW ENFORCEMENT
SAYING THAT THE RUBBER BULLETS
ON PROTESTERS PAVE THE WAY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO MAKE THIS
WALK TO ST. JOHN’S CHURCH, THE
PRESIDENT WAS BACK AT ANOTHER
PLACE OF PRAYER, BUT THIS MOMENT
OF REMEMBRANCE WAS QUICKLY
FOLLOWED BY A SCATHING STATEMENT
FROM THE ARCHBISHOP OF
WASHINGTON WHO SAID I FIND IT
BAFFLING AND REPREHENSIBLE THAT
ANY CATHOLIC FACILITY WOULD
ALLOW ITSELF TO BE SO
EGREGIOUSLY MISUSED AND
MANIPULATED.
AND TODAY OUTSIDE ST. JOHN’S
CHURCH.
--
>> WE ARE HERE TO REPAIR.
>> BUT KELLYANNE CONWAY SAYS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOTHING TO
REPENT FOR.
>> WHY DID HE FEEL COMPELLED TO
WALK THERE.
THAT IS A SYMBOL TO EVERYONE
THAT WE WILL NOT ALLOW ARSONISTS
AND ANARCHISTS WHO SET THE FIRE
ABLAZE.
>> ACCORDING TO A SENIOR
OFFICIAL, THE DECISION TO WIDEN
THE PERIMETER AROUND THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS MADE EARLY
MONDAY MORNING, BUT WHEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR
ARRIVED IN LAFAYETTE SQUARE, THE
PLAN HAD NOT YET BEEN EXECUTED.
THE OFFICIAL CLAIMS A PROTESTER
THROUGH A WATER BOTTLE AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND THAT’S
WHEN BILL BARR GAVE THE ORDER TO
PUSH PROTESTERS BACK BEFORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WALKED OUT.
SPEAK WITH THE POLICE DID NOT
RESPOND OTHER THAN MOVING THE
PROTESTERS BACK.
BUT I THOUGHT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DID AND THE CHURCH WAS NOT ONLY
APPROPRIATE, IT WAS NEEDED.
>> SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER CALLS IT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AND ABUSE OF
PRESIDENTIAL POWER AND POSSIBLY
ILLEGAL.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ORDERED TROOPS TO
ATTACK PEACEFUL AMERICAN
CITIZENS, EXERCISING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS BY TEAR
GASSING THEM AT A PUBLIC PARK
WHILE MILITARY HELICOPTERS
THROUGH